alors heureusement quand Lando il vous a
pas vu avant de vous entendre parce que
quand il vous a vu il faut dire les
choses
de nombreux appels à Orlando le
producteur d'Hélène Segara pour qui
l'autorise son artiste Hélène Ségara
donc à venir sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle parce que jamais venu non
il veut pas
je lance un appel Orlando sois gentil
laisse l'avenir
il veut pas pourquoi
Monaco
beaucoup beaucoup d'emails sur Hélène
Segara parce que vous savez Gérard
Orlando le producteur d'Hélène Segara ne
veut pas qu'elle aime Vienne dans
l'émission donc Jean-François Lanoux de
Lille dit Orlando qui interdit tout le
monde en parle Hélène Ségara c'est un
taliban
de Neuilly qui veut créer le Comité de
Libération d'Hélène Segara création à
Levallois d'une association pour la
libération d'Hélène Segara
que son producteur Orlando refuse de
laisser venir dans tout le monde en
parle donc Hélène t'en fais pas on est
avec toi il y a des associations qui
seraient dans toute la France et on ne
sortira de la ln t'en fais pas à part ça
donc on me demande des nouvelles de la
négociation pour la libération de Hélène
Ségara
Hélène Ségara est toujours prisonnière
de du taliban Orlando qui veut pas les
laisser sortir Catherine barman négocier
on risque de bientôt retrouver Hélène
Segara voilà justement beaucoup beaucoup
de gens aussi militent pour la
libération d'Hélène Ségara qui est
toujours détenu par le taliban Orlando
en tous les cas je promets Orlando que
lorsque Hélène Segara viendra elle
n'aura pas une interview chienne
elle est là avec le ce soir
est-ce que vous pouvez enlever la burqa
s'il vous plaît
bien alors Hélène le taliban landau a
évité de justesse le Tribunal pénal
international de La Haye vous avez été
traité comment durant votre captivité en
fait les talibans le taliban c'est pas
Orlando c'est mon travail quand même
parce qu'en ce moment et depuis plus de
deux ans je suis en tournée et donc
quand je rentre sur Paris quand j'ai pas
de concert je fais j'ai enregistré un
album en espagnol j'ai
pas un jour à moi
alors nous avions parfois des nouvelles
de vous Hélène par exemple
j'ai reçu un mail de Gravelines dans le
59 et le monsieur qui m'écrit dit la
belle donnait un concert à Gravelines ce
que je peux dire c'est qu'avait l'air
bien soigné ouais les gens me donnaient
des nouvelles par contre il y avait des
gros balèzes partout et après le concert
j'ai dû répondre aux questions de mes
filles qui ont huit et 10 ans papa c'est
qui Orlando
papa c'est quoi un taliban écoutez il
est tard les filles on essaie de dormir
un peu c'est ce qui est Stéphane
Gravelines voilà alors Hélène j'imagine
quand même que si le taliban ça va dû
rester là maintenant de toute façon le
talibor Orlando c'est pour toute sa vie
j'imagine que si le taliban Orlando vous
a libéré c'est qu'il y a un peu de promo
dans l'air il y a un single
assez inattendu d'ailleurs puisque on
devait pas être aussi rapide on a on
avait décidé de préparer les nouvelles
albums en avril et un après-midi Orlando
m'a appelé et puis m'a dit j'ai une idée
de chanson ça correspond aux premières
années de ma vie que j'ai passé en
Italie et enchanté tout le temps ça dans
la voiture à l'époque donc c'est un je
pense que c'est 76 77 quelque chose
comme ça c'est une chanson italienne
vous êtes d'origine italienne par votre
père donc alors il y a en plus une
tournée à partir du 26 février prochain
15 villes de France dont l'Olympia
l'Olympia de Paris du 19 au 25 mars elle
voulait aller à l'Olympia de Melun puis
finalement c'était moins bien
alors succès considérable de votre album
au nom d'une femme le deuxième album qui
est sorti il y a deux ans c'est vendu à
un million 500 000 exemplaires c'est la
plus grosse vente de l'an 2000 rien à
voir avec Lara Fabian
vous êtes né en 1971 à La Seyne-sur-Mer
dans le Var votre père Bernard Rizzo
c'est votre vrai nom alors votre père
c'est terrible parce que licence de
philo foot littérature fou d'opéra ténor
et puis un jour voilà il se marie et
puis votre maman Thérèse surtout
enceinte de votre sœur aînée Magalie
c'est un jeune papa alors il prend le
premier boulot venu il devient employé
de bureau au chantier
ça a été ça a été la plus grande
tristesse de sa vie de devoir oublier
ses projets pour assumer son rôle de
papa
complètement
alors votre mère Thérèse fonctionnait au
Trésor public et puis alors le drame en
plus Thérèse et fonctionnaire le Trésor
Public
c'était bien qu'elle en est attrapé un
déjà
non mais
c'est vrai que c'était pas gagné et
comme quoi
et le problème c'est que ça dure pas en
plus elle est divorce Thérèse remarie
vous aimez pas beaucoup votre beau-père
il y a une petite tendance à être portée
sur la boisson
et alors heureusement il meurt
comme quoi non mais comme quoi toi
c'est vrai qu'il est décédé à 40 ans
d'une cirrhose du feu
alors et vous vous aimez bien le
troisième ah oui
beaucoup de bonheur
enfin mon deuxième beau-père s'appelle
Alain mais comme c'est MacGyver et qu'il
a réparé mon sèche-linge avec un bouchon
de Bic je l'appelle Bikou
alors votre maman elle est géniale votre
maman parce que elle vous voit là en ce
moment elle vous voit à la télé elle
sait exactement ce que vous ressentez
c'est vrai elle voulait venir avec sa
batte de baseball ce soir je sais pas la
peine maman
je suis ceinture noire de cuisine
italienne donc et donc c'est vrai que ma
maman elle sait exactement et Orlando
d'ailleurs aussi comme ça ils sont deux
je peux arriver avec le sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles en fait
alors voilà toute petite voulait être
prof de français ou avocate mais en même
temps vous aviez un don un talent chaque
fois qu'avec le Clos qui passait à la
télé vous montiez sur la table ça s'en
va et ça revient et voilà
et Pépé qui était content surtout quand
vous chantiez Nana Mouskouri quand vous
chantiez Mireille Mathieu
je connais pas juste comme ça la mélodie
pour les 100.000 ans qui viennent
donnez-nous mis le colombe
il m'a fait goûter le vin sucré et donc
j'ai trouvé ça très très bien à 6 ans le
vin sucré et un jour
secret de mon pépé
quand tu étais malade Vous mangez tous
les deux vous lui donniez à manger vous
lui donnez à manger
c'est vrai que quatre ans après ma sœur
maman devait plus avoir d'enfant
physiquement et un soir par hasard mon
père a rencontré ma mère dans la chambre
et donc
c'est vrai que je suis arrivée par
accident et maman passait des concours
internes à ce moment-là pour monter en
grade mon père travaillait et on a
décidé de me confier à mes
grands-parents beaucoup et mon
grand-père sortait d'une opération d'un
cancer très grave on se réapprenant à
manger il m'a appris à manger en
m'apprenant à marcher c'est après à
marcher et puis mes parents quand même
tenu quatre avant de se dire adieu alors
quand vous avez 11 ans vous faites un
scène Harry le concours du micro d'or et
vous gagnez la finale d'abord la
demi-finale vous revenez en finale et là
vous chantez l'amour héritage c'est
comment la mort américaine non mais je
sais pas non c'est des chansons que je
connais pas voilà j'ai reçu l'amour en
héritage un matin au pays des cigales la
folie le gén
Ie vache bien au-delà du temps bien à
part dessus les océans
en même temps quand la troupe artistique
de Sanary vous propose de faire quelques
spectacles avec eux mes parents disent
non c'est pas un métier
d'abord elle va à l'école et résultat de
cette attitude à 14 ans vous fuguez
Hélène Ségara pour faire de la musique
vous chantez dans les bars dans les
restaurants de la Côte d'Azur c'est dur
d'autant plus qu'à l'époque on peut le
dire parce que maintenant ça a beaucoup
changé à l'époque j'étais quand même pas
pu dire quoi pas très jolie
qui fait de l'ombre à personne et
je suis plutôt boulotte je suis pas
d'ailleurs j'ai des personnes qui sont
venues me montrer une photo qui m'avait
fait et qu'ils avaient prise de moi à
l'époque et j'avais des dédicacé la
photo en disant je suis moche mais je
compte pas rester toute ma vie
alors vous êtes mal dans votre peau vous
avez un sentiment de pas exister à
l'époque
j'aime bien ni moi ni
c'est une période assez glauque je crois
pour moi
parce que des fois une petite boulette
en fin de soirée ça peut faire la fête
alors
non vas-y fini
jusqu'à 25 ans vous n'avez connu qu'un
seul homme
non jusqu'à 23 ans je n'ai connu qu'un
très naïf très timide
totalement de confiance en moi alors cet
homme c'est le père de votre fils
Raphaël qui naît quand vous avez 18 ans
et vous êtes séparé avant la naissance
vous vous souvenez de la prédiction
d'Augustin le grand-père maternel et un
jour ce grand-père est en train de
mourir de son concerts dans un semi-coma
et il vous dit je te vois sur une scène
il y a des lumières d'or tu chantes à la
télévision
il m'a même dit mieux c'est que mon
grand-père regardait la chance aux
chansons à l'époque et donc c'est vrai
qu'il était déjà dans un autre monde et
il m'a dit que toute sa vie il avait vu
les choses avant qu'elles arrivent et
tous ces frères sont morts il a vu
mourir ses frères à chaque fois avant
que ça arrive donc il allait et buvait
du vin rouge jusqu'à oublier ce qu'il
avait aperçu dans sa tête et il m'a dit
c'est la première image gay que j'ai
heureuse j'ai regardé la chance aux
chansons et le visage de cette chanteuse
disparaissait il n'y avait plus que le
tien et ça rassemblera la famille et il
est mort et moi j'ai souri quand il a
dit ça parce que évidemment je pensais
pas que ça pouvait arriver alors ensuite
de 86 à 92 vous écumez les bars du Sud
notamment à Hyères c'est une très bonne
école quelqu'un regrets là-dessus même
si c'était une période très galère j'ai
appris beaucoup sur l'être humain le
soir vous chantez de 21h à 1h du matin
ah oui mais après même de 22h à 4h du
matin le premier contrat sur Paris
c'est ça c'est fermé maintenant
du Sud sont plus ou moins liés à ce
qu'on appelle le milieu oui ils sont
explosifs mais moi ce patron m'a engagé
j'étais enceinte de mon petit garçon il
m'a fait manger pendant 4 ans je le
remercie bien sûr
normal
et puis un jour elle aime Segara vous
décidez de monter à Paris ça s'est passé
comment j'ai commencé à partir
travailler sur Nice et sur Monaco et là
à Monaco on m'a offert une place en or
et mon patron était super sympa j'étais
nourri logée j'avais vraiment une belle
place c'est la première fois de ma vie
que j'ai arrêté de galérer et ça m'a
fait peur cette stabilité je me suis dit
tu vas t'endormir sur tes lauriers et je
voyais beaucoup de copines qui
arrivaient qui étaient toujours
chanteuse en piano bar elles avaient 35
ans et qui commençait à avoir du mal à
trouver du boulot et qu'on moi j'avais
22 ans
et je suis partie à Paris sur un coup de
tête
je connaissais personne j'ai squatté le
grenier de mon de la sœur de mon ami
doudou pendant plusieurs mois à Clamart
et c'était j'aimais pas du tout j'avais
aucun ami donc déjà c'était un petit peu
difficile je suis repartie une première
fois et puis entre-temps j'avais fait
une maquette dans le loin et je vous
aime adieu et ça intéressait quelqu'un
et je suis remis
le vrai succès viendra avec la rencontre
avec Orlando alors heureusement quand
landeau il vous a pas vu avant de vous
entendre parce que quand il vous a vu
faut dire les choses il a Gerbert
le visage trop maquillé vous pesiez 10
kilos de plus que qu'aujourd'hui perdre
la caméra aussi énormément et d'ailleurs
si mes premières télé je penchais
beaucoup la tête j'avais les jambes de
rentrer vers l'intérieur c'était
terrible pour moi parce que mon papa
n'est pas de photos avant que je
commence à être connu il y a même pas
une photo de moi
donc j'avais un léger problème avec les
objectifs et j'ai pris des cours avec
une amie pour ça pour accepter ce machin
là
tu t'habitues
à regarder la caméra vous apprenez à
sourire et puis après il y a ça
son dernier single voilà alors gros
succès on l'a dit tout à l'heure
deuxième album meilleur vente de disques
en l'an 2000 gros succès mais aussi
grosse galère par exemple un jour vous
perdez votre voix sur la scène à
Montréal alors que vous êtes dans Notre
Dame de Paris du muscle du larynx un
kyste en plus un kyste hémorragique je
fais l'hémorragie le pire moment c'est
quand le médecin de Céline Dion vous dit
que vous êtes inopérable vous chanterez
plus jamais dans excusez-moi peut-être
que le mec il faisait ça pour aider
Céline Dion
à Montréal à New York et en France sur 3
il y en a trois qui m'ont dit que je
chanterai plus jamais et puis là bon je
peux le dire parce que Jean habite bol
qui est un docteur français
dans le cas où tu retrouves ta voix
depuis avoir la même voix et alors là
Orlando extraordinaire Orlando il vient
au Canada et au moment où vous êtes dans
le pire état il vous dit tu rechantera
et il vous demande de préparer un album
c'est à dire que à ce moment là
je suis pas en licence directe avec
Orlando j'ai un producteur indépendant
qui me doit beaucoup d'argent
Orlando à ce moment-là cet homme là tout
à coup est très intéressé pour revendre
mon contrat à tout Paris et à ce moment
là Orlando lui rachète mon contrat
pour beaucoup d'argent et que je lui dis
mais tu es fou tu as racheter un cheval
qui court à plus il m'a dit si si je
justement parce que j'ai fait ça tu vas
voir tu vas y arriver alors je crois
qu'il y a pas beaucoup de producteurs
aujourd'hui qui sont capables de faire
parce que j'ai fait ça tu rechantera et
ça c'est vraiment c'était bien joué ça
autre drame dans votre vie damien Sargue
ah j'en étais sûr
Roméo de Roméo et Juliette
dans Notre Dame de Paris
c'est pas vrai mais tu mens je te jure
que non ça a été terrible ça a posé des
problèmes oui
vous avez un moment vous avez eu peur
quand vous traite de chanteuses aminer
alors que d'habitude c'est plutôt des
chanteurs à minette
ou Pascal Obispo qui se marie avec des
femmes qui
ont vainqueur c'est normal moi je me
suis pas mariée j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
je me suis prise d'affection pour ce
garçon je suis pas tombée raide
amoureuse et j'ai vécu quelque chose de
joli je crois que j'ai été très
maternelle et très protectrice avec lui
ça s'est arrêté parce que dès que les
ailes lui ont poussé s'est envolé comme
grand et que les médias nous ont
empoisonné la vie j'ai jamais cherché à
communiquer je connais des tas
d'artistes qui ont vendu des photos à
certains canards pour faire parler d'eux
de leur vie privée moi jamais j'ai vendu
une photo de Damien et moi ça m'est
jamais arrivé et on s'est retrouvé comme
un feuilleton à épisode jusqu'au moment
où j'ai accepté de communiquer une fois
et malheureusement pour moi c'est on
s'est séparé entre le moment où c'est
sorti et j'en pouvais plus et moi qui ai
arrêté les choses je regrette pas ce que
j'aimerais c'est que aujourd'hui
j'aimerais passer à autre chose et donc
que les gens passent à autre chose pour
moi et pour lui aussi mais il a eu des
pressions de son entourage professionnel
lui non je pense oui
c'est peut-être pas bien pour lui penser
non c'est son problème
j'ai trop protégé moi maintenant je vais
me protéger moi
aujourd'hui ça va vous avez quelqu'un
dans votre vie ça va très bien
là-dessus
voici le moment que toute la France
attend
c'est l'interview psy de Hélène Segara
est-ce que vous êtes en surcom monstre
tout simplement est-ce que vous êtes
maniako non grande désespoir de beaucoup
pas du tout
est-ce que vous êtes mytho j'aime pas ça
non mégalo
ça fait maintenant 20 minutes que
j'attends mon verre
parce que vous êtes parano
non pas du tout
vous êtes cyclo
[ __ ] vélo moi
attention parlons pas de vélo c'est ce
qui se passe quand on parle de vélo
est-ce que vous êtes nains
mais peut-être sauf pour
exceptionnellement pour venir ici ce
soir est-ce que vous êtes ça
je vais le devenir aussi
bon je m'endors si vous êtes pédo parce
qu'avec Damien c'était un petit peu de
la pédophilie
j'ai honte de moi
pour être équipé d'eau est-ce que vous
êtes gigolo
non mais si
je le si je le fus ce fut inconscient
alors d'accord
cheveux longs donc peut-être qu'il y a
quelque chose à creuser
et en plus de ça
j'en suis super fier parce que je peux
dire que la grand-mère ma grand-mère et
ma mère qui m'ont éduqué m'ont pas
éduqué pour rien je suis très heureuse
comme ça
on parle souvent de pétard dans cette
émission Le Buteur pas plus grave qu'un
verre de whisky en revanche en revanche
il y a maintenant des produits qui
viennent d'Amsterdam qui sont enrichis
en THC et qui sont très dangereux voilà
le THC c'est le principe qui défonce
dans le shit quoi si tu veux et ils sont
enrichis d'une façon scientifique tu
veux et ça faut vraiment faire gaffe
voilà je voulais dire ça j'ai mes petits
mes petits Gremlins mes petits héros de
la tout le monde fume un peu ce bordel
et un coup il me disent tiens vas-y je
suis pas je suis pas tellement ça
c'était je sais pas quoi je te jure que
j'étais dans ma chambre d'hôtel j'ai
fait une taf comme ça je dis bon bah je
vais me coucher je suis rentré à la
chambre d'hôtel j'avais la télécommande
comme ça je voyais la télé j'étais dans
la télé
impossible de zapper
regardez un truc lamentable à la télé
comme ça c'était un vendredi soir
impossible de mettre la couverture sur
moi j'étais gelé comme ça je suis resté
deux heures à cauchemar un vrai
semblable est-ce que vous êtes sanglots
je sais un petit peu où vous voulez en
venir c'est que c'est vrai que je pleure
facilement mais
je suis motivé par contre comme je suis
plus dit que je pleurais en public je
peux pleurer que de joie mes chagrins je
les montrerai jamais est-ce que vous
êtes Orlando
le jour où je serais plus ça sera
peut-être la fin mais je suis Orlando
j'ai même dit que le jour où il allait
Hélène
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu